by November the first British politics
will have undergone another revolution
there are only five possible outcomes so
option one is the forest Johnson gets a
deal hopefully with a deal mister speak
up and get it three Parliament's it's
agreed on all sides of the house you'd
have had to swallow some pretty big
compromises to get there all persuaded
the ear used to be the same by the way
try out option two is that it gives in I
will not ask for another delay it is
feasible that he comes back from that
mid-october summit with nothing and
feels the heat from cabinet colleagues
it's option two is that he complies with
the law rights to Brussels
to ask for an extension to Breck's add a
capitulation but it's just more likely
that he tries to fight now we're gearing
up for an epic constitutional clash in
the last week of October 4 here at the
Supreme Court and in the Commons with
MPs that option 3 sees him lose and
still have to go crawling back to
Brussels to ask for that extension will
iation humiliation humiliated so options
for is a No Deal brexit he faces down
opposition from the courts and from MPs
might win now I think this is the only
way you end up with a No Deal brexit
this year but he still taken Britain out
of the EU on his timescale we're going
to come out Deal or No Deal on October
the 31st but it's to a No Deal brexit
which introduces uncertainty for an
unknown length of time freezing then
there's the wild card option 5 resigning
as Prime Minister in order to hand over
to kiss Dharma or king club or even
Jeremy Corbyn and then let them delay
brexit day
you really want to delay brexit beyond
October the 31st and vote for an
election option five has been discussed
around whitehall but cabinet minister
say it's really unlikely the idea then
would be that you'd have a general
election in which the Tories would crush
a remain leaning opposition aside but
there is no such thing as a temporary
prime minister and you do have to be
careful what you wish for it's risky all
of this assumes that if Britain asks for
an EU extension it gets it but any
assumption in British politics is risky